I'm embarrassed to tell you that for a
couple years I believed it when 9/11
came the American news media was
weaponized and it came at us from every
direction that Muslims had invaded
America and they were going to kill us
and the American people were very afraid
we were afraid if we met a Muslim on the
street they might pull out a knife and
try to chop off our head and this came
at us from every direction the American
people had never had these thoughts ever
I don't recall ever having these kind of
thoughts but after 9/11 the propaganda
already been formulated had been
designed and it was simply being
implemented it came from every direction
television the news it got into the
movies and the Hollywood movies and then
it got into the churches and the
churches were told Beware of the Muslims
they're coming to America to kill the
Christians I'm sad to tell you I'm
embarrassed to tell you that for a
couple years I believed it I didn't know
what was happening to my country it took
me a couple years to figure out the game
plan we had been told a lot